c'est vrai que ça te dérange tant à
barbie franchement là l'afrique j'avais
comme maintenant vous avez 7 barbichette
sa fin du jeûne donne une dizaine allez
vous l'avez jamais coupé jamais jamais
jamais mais comment sam et or pousse et
ça c'est pas les longues allées juin
bien vu les longues allées
j'ai envie de lancer hashtag fini la
barbiche non pas si jean-louis d'anciens
goethe est finie la barbiche mais comme
là ça serait un gros gros gros des flux
en tête pour l'approcher non non non ça
sera plus aaa
la fouine si on arrive à avoir mais là
j'ai là je vais mettre là bas mais
vraiment très très haut maintenant je
vous le dis parce que d'éveil twitter
non non non on va mettre là bas sans
cent mille tweets non alors moi je dis
non merci pendant huit semaines parce
que c'est un événement quand même la
barre balzac à la fouine si aujourd'hui
ça s'est ressenti en un comme si on
allait voir c'est un événement à venir
citons les aura pas je pense pour les
enfants aux cent mille tweets
si on arrive à avoir 100 milles qu'ils
n'assurent pas qui le fera de façon fini
la barbiche hashtag fini la barbiche
poupe
on lui fera on fera la fouine une
deuxième circoncision on a lancé
hashtags est finie la barbiche pour la
fouine voilà si on arrive à cent mille
tweets de fini la barbiche eh bien on
bien sûr on ira chercher un secteur bien
sûr et on verra alors on a combien pour
l'instant du disque on peut faire un
point 7477 les séries et sachez le c'est
maintenant que ça se joue à alesi chose
qui ressemble à votre famille a bien sûr
il faut arriver à 100 milles à 20h07
très précises 20h07
qu'on arrête les comptes tak tak
badaboum carmine et donc c'est
exactement dans 19h12 20h07 le calcul
est trop compliqué dit la barbie je vous
connaissais la fouine la fuite il a une
barbichette depuis combien de temps
cette barbie comme des artisans disant
qu'il a ce critérium comme ça voilà ici
voilà ici un critérium il instille aux
quatre couleurs
il est très dur on dit ça ça vous change
le
c'est un peu d'ambiance
j'adore rigoler c'est tu as aimé vous
mettez du yen je mets de la cire mais ça
c'est à dire m'a donné si de la cire max
oui brushing je le vaux bien
ah d'accord merci pour couper en petits
os vous croyez vous fait une publicité
gratuite et lucio midi il est grave c b
car il adore alors la fouine on a lancé
un hashtag fini la barbiche on va faire
un point tout de suite pour savoir à
combien on est on est à peu près on en a
demandé 100 milles je vous le dis on
peut les faire si vous vous mobilisez il
nous reste à peu près 20 minutes même
plus de 20 minutes 23 minutes exactement
franchement mobilisez vous c'est
normalement à ce moment là qu'on fait le
plus de tweets
donc on peut les faire vous avez 20
minutes pour faire 80 mille tweets voilà
et pour qu'on lui arrache un set
barbiche qui est dégueulasse on va pas
se mentir lui ça lui va bien
mais elle sera très bien aussi sur
isabelle morini-bosc us ont lu et relu y
fera ensuite comme ça et vous aussi un
petit peu dur ça vous fera du bien on
les voit et motivés en disant qu'on
offrira la la barbiche le 100e et roux
cent millième vote
merci vous être et c'est très sympa
quand vous serez quand vous serez
directeur des programmes de la chaîne
vous ferez ce que vous pour le pourquoi
on va faire juste un petit point sur
fini la barge parce qu'on a décidé
d'aller jusqu'à 20h40 on va voir les
plus raisonnables
je rappelle je rappelle pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent
si on a 100 me sens libre tweet donc sur
fini la barbiche et bien bien sûr il la
cupra un la fouine pour l'instant storm
et à combien ridicule et 44,1 40000
pendant faire soixante mille ans
exactement 32 minutes ça va rien donner
j'ai un moyen il ya moyen de le faire on
y croit encore moi moi j'y crois encore
on aura le nombre de tweets pour la
barbiche 2 la fouine on a demandé 100
mille tweets
vous avez été énorme sachez le vous avez
été énorme parce que il ya de ça pas
longtemps et en servant la cinq minutes
on m'a donné les chiffres j ai pas cru
je vous donnais le chiffre dans un
instant voilà vous continuez à tweeté il
vous reste exactement minutes
allez-y finie la barbie avant ils sont
mille tweets à nous regrouper mes yeux
la barbichette de la fouine
c'est énorme et avant tout vous votre
barbichette c'est votre vie quand même
la fuite plus ou moins
non franchement si vous perdez votre
barbichette c'est à la fin de la
carrière
non mais j'aurais perdu une partie de
moi-même partie de ça fait combien de
temps que vous l'avez déjà dix en dix
ans on a demandé aux téléspectateurs
on a lancé le hashtag fini la barbiche
on va voir tout de suite le nombre si on
est à plus de 100 milles
on amènera une paire de ciseaux et les
joueurs n'occuperait j'ai déjà fait
si on a à moins de 100 milles vous
gardez votre barre michek bonsoir c'est
à quel sujet merci on sait jamais au cas
où s'est jamais si vous avez été très
nombreux
regardez plus de 100 mime ou moins 200
mines
c'est parti
non pas mal
ils doivent savoir me choque
on encore
google